MARTIN OMANDER: Hello.
My name is Martin Omander.
And I welcome you to "Google
Root Access," the show where
startups and investors
share their experiences
and lessons they've learned.
Today, I'm joined by Nicolai
Wadstrom from the investor
BootstrapLabs.
Nicolai, would you tell us
a bit about BootstrapLabs?
NICOLAI WADSTROM: So we are
a global venture investment
company, and we try to
find top talented founders
from around the
world, invest in them,
and help them build
global companies.
What makes us a
little bit different
is that we don't really
care where they're from,
if they're from Silicon
Valley or outside.
And the majority
of our deal flow
actually comes from
outside of Silicon Valley.
But we always bring part
of a team to Silicon Valley
to benefit from this fantastic
ecosystem to build companies.
But they usually stay
and build-- at the end,
they usually have more employees
where they originally started.
So we're trying
to keep that hub.
One good example of a
past portfolio company
is a company called Prezi,
which started in Budapest,
in Hungary, about
five years ago.
So they've grown from
six people back then
to 270 something,
I think, today.
MARTIN OMANDER: It's
a great product.
I've used it.
NICOLAI WADSTROM: Yeah.
I love it.
It's amazing.
And that's the exciting thing.
People get so excited
about the product itself.
It sells itself, in a sense.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great.
So Nicolai, both you
and I have a past
as programmers and
chasing semicolons
and such, which is great fun.
But some people say that
technology doesn't really
matter.
All that matters is
the idea or the team.
Others say the
technology is very
important for what platform
or technology a startup picks.
When you look at
investments, do you
look at the technology
a startup's built on?
NICOLAI WADSTROM: Absolutely.
I think it's super important.
But the core thing
is really, really,
of course, the team
and the ability
to execute at the
end of the day.
So because we invest early on
in a post-accelerate or seed
stage, having a technology
background for me
is very helpful to understand
what they're building,
how competitive the opportunity
is, and all these things.
But looking at technology early
on and how they go about it
is really crucial
for us to understand
how that team
thinks, and how they
try to use that as
an advantage to move
faster and quicker,
figure things out.
So as a team, it's
the most important.
But technology--
down the line, it
becomes really,
really crucial how
they apply
technology, of course.
MARTIN OMANDER: How they
apply technology, got it.
Yeah, got it.
So do you still program
any, by the way?
NICOLAI WADSTROM: I do.
I try to keep pretty brilliant.
If I leave my Swedish
culture behind,
I'm actually damn good still.
I'm pretty good.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, good, great.
I try to program a little every
now and then as well, just
to keep the skills sharp.
NICOLAI WADSTROM: Some real
work every now and then.
MARTIN OMANDER: Some
real work, there we go.
So what are your criteria for
determining if a technology
that a startup has is
interesting right now,
or if it isn't?
NICOLAI WADSTROM: Well, so
looking at new innovation
ideas-- and yes,
it's about ideas.
But we invest in technology.
So being able to
apply technology
at the end of the day that has
impact and great efficiencies
is really important.
Vetting criteria we look at--
let's step back a second,
so looking at areas where
we go in and invest,
and deciding if whatever
these founders are very
passionate about
and trying to build
is relevant and interesting.
I try to look at the bigger
technology landscape.
It becomes-- I build software.
It becomes like an architecture
map of the value chain
from one end to another where
value is being received.
And some of these pieces of
technology are commoditized.
And that's an
advantage, because that
means you can focus on
building value on top.
Like Clayton Christensen says,
when it becomes commoditized,
the value and innovation
is above and below, right?
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, right.
NICOLAI WADSTROM: So
it's the same thinking.
So look at pieces.
And there's lots of things
through open source software
libraries that are
readily available,
and things like that,
that you can use, and then
iterate much quicker
on top of that.
There are services like
the Google App Engine
that allows you to focus
maybe on the functionality
of your app that's
closer to where you add
value on your mobile phone,
versus a lot of infrastructure
on the back end to scale.
And early on, this becomes
really even more important.
Because when you iterate and try
to find a product market where
it's really relevant or
where people even care about,
the quicker you can move, the
better-- how you get to build
data points and validate
those assumptions.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Ah, right, I see.
So that actually leads me
to the next question, which
is, some people say,
build quick and dirty.
You're going to
throw it away anyway.
And others say, no.
You're actually going to
build a business on this
and make revenue.
You need to build something
that works snf scales.
I imagine the startups
that you invest in,
you give them advice on this.
What kind of advice
do you give them?
NICOLAI WADSTROM: Yeah, so
it's a very good question.
Because somebody comes
out and will say,
should I do this
quick and dirty,
or should I build
a stable platform?
And the CEO says,
build quick and dirty.
And the CEO says, no, no, no.
It needs to be a
stable platform so we
can-- at the end of the
day, our advice is really,
this changes over time.
A startup goes through phases
and metamorphoses between them.
Early on, it's
really, really crucial
just to find what
people care about.
So you build
quickly, push it out,
get data points, what
people really care about,
assumptions to turn
into data points.
And you measure, you learn,
and you iterate that way.
Once you figure those things
out, a lot of mechanics
change-- how we
apply technology,
lots of other pieces
of the startup,
how you scale ten users.
And there's a lot of
growth hacking aspects.
But if you talk about the
technology, all of a sudden,
you need to be able to
sustain heavy load, growth,
and all these things.
So a proper technology
platform that can handle that
becomes really important
really quickly.
And a lot of startups,
that is a hard job.
Because from iterating quickly,
you're hacking things together
to test.
And all of a sudden,
it takes off.
So what do you do?
So again, I think there's a
lot of ready-made commodity
solutions that you don't
need to build yourself
that you can rely on to
quickly transition into that.
And I like the
mix of App Engine,
the platform as a service.
Because you remove
a lot of complexity
on storing massive amounts of
data and retrieving it quickly,
the scale out of your web
servers, and all that.
But for other pieces,
you might need
to really manage
parts of these things.
For heavy processing and
analytics and all these things,
you might need to build
an infrastructure.
Using infrastructure
services is what everybody
of our startups use.
They don't have
their own service.
Well, there's one exception.
But everybody else used
really an infrastructure
as a service, Google
Compute Engine,
for example, to assemble bricks
to get it quickly up and down,
and scale up when you
need lots of processing,
and scale down when you
don't, and things like that.
MARTIN OMANDER: So when do you
advise startups to use platform
as a service, as
Google App Engine,
versus infrastructure
as a service,
like Google Compute Engine?
NICOLAI WADSTROM: So
it comes down to that.
If most of the value add of
the product they're building
and they're iterating on is on
the front end in a mobile app
or such, I think the
App Engine is perfect.
Because you can build
an-- and I think
it's much better
than things like Path
where you can't really
program the back end.
But an app engine,
Google App Engine,
you still will deploy
your applications.
And you can still build
a lot of logic and value
add on the back end, which
is important, in my view,
to differentiate.
But you take away some of the
scaling issues and all those,
you can be really
focused on that value.
On the other hand,
again, let's say
you have massive
amounts of data where
you need to do
customized analytics
and analyze that data.
You usually need to
build some Hadoop cluster
and some processing,
and customize
a lot of things
that happen on top.
Then I would recommend
to use the Google Compute
Engine for that.
MARTIN OMANDER: Interesting.
Well, thank you
very much, Nicolai,
for your time in coming
on here and telling us
about and sharing
your experiences.
NICOLAI WADSTROM: Of course.
MARTIN OMANDER: We hope
you found something
you can use in your startup.
Your input matters.
Please leave your
comments below.
We read everything you write.
To learn how Google
can help your startup,
go to
developers.google.com/startups.
If you would like to
be a guest on the show,
go to bit.ly/applyrootaccess.
That's it for now.
See you next time.